Let's learn about matrices.
What do I mean when
I say matrices?
Well, matrices is just the
plural for matrix, which is
probably a word you're familiar
with more because of
Hollywood than because
of mathematics.
So what is a matrix?
Well, it's actually a
pretty simple idea.
It's just a table of numbers,
that's all a matrix is.
So let me draw matrix for you.
I don't like that
toothpaste-colored blue, so
let me use another color.
So this is an example
of a matrix.
I'm going to pick some random
numbers out: 5, 1,
2, 3, 0, minus 5.
That is a matrix.
And all it is is a
table of numbers.
And often times if you wanted
to have a variable for a
matrix, you'd use a capital
letter, so you could use a
capital A, and sometimes in some
books, they make it extra
bold, so like a bold A
would be a matrix.
And just a little bit of
notation, so we would call
this matrix, just by convention,
you would call
this a 2-by-3 matrix.
And sometimes they actually
write it, 2 by 3, below the
bold letter they use to
represent the matrix.
And what is 2 and what is 3?
Well, 2 is the number of rows.
We have one row, two
rows, right?
This is a row.
And we have three columns:
one, two, three.
So that's why it's called
a 2-by-3 matrix.
If I said that B-- I'll do it
extra bold-- if B is a 5-by-2
matrix, that means that B would
have--- I'll just type
in numbers: 0, minus 5, 10.
So it has five rows and it has
two columns, so it'll have
another column here.
So let's see, minus 10, 3, I'm
just putting in random numbers
here-- 7, 2, pi.
That is a 5-by-2 matrix.
So I think you now have kind
of a convention that all a
matrix is is a table
of numbers.
You can represent it
when you're doing
it in variable form.
You represent it as a boldface
capital letter.
Sometimes you'd write
a 2 by 3 there.
And, you can actually
reference the
terms of the matrix.
So in this example, in the top
example where we have matrix
A, if someone wanted to
reference this element of the
matrix, so what is that?
That is in the second row.
It's in row 2 and it's
in column 2, right?
This is column 1, this
is column 2.
This is row 1, row 2.
So it's in the second
row, second column.
So sometimes people will write
that A, and they'll write 2
comma 2 is equal to 0.
Or sometimes they'll write it as
a lowercase A 2 comma 2 is
equal to 0.
These are just the same thing.
I'm just doing this to expose
you to the notation, because a
lot of this really
is just notation.
So what is a 1 comma 3?
Well, that means we're in the
first row, the third column.
First row, one, two, three, it's
this value right here.
So that equals 2.
So this is just all notation
of what a matrix is.
It's a table of numbers that
can be represented this way
and we can represent it as
different elements that way.
So you might be asking, Sal,
well, that's nice.
A table of numbers with fancy
words and fancy notations, but
what is it good for?
And that's the interesting
point.
A matrix is just a data
representation.
It's just a way of writing
down data.
That's all it is.
it's a table of numbers, but it
can be used to represent a
whole set of phenomenon.
And if soon. you're doing this
in your Algebra I or your
Algebra II class, you're
probably using it to represent
linear equations.
But we'll learn later-- and I'll
do a whole set of videos
on applying matrices
to a whole bunch
of different things.
But it can represent-- it's very
powerful and if you're
doing computer graphics on a
matrix, the elements can
represent pixels
on your screen.
They can represent points
in coordinate space.
They can represent--
who knows?
There's tons of things that
they can represent.
But the important thing to
realize is that a matrix, it's
not a natural phenomenon.
It's not like a lot of the
mathematical concepts we've
been looking at.
It's a way to represent a
mathematical concept or a way
of representing values, but
you kind of have to define
what it's representing.
But let's put that on the back
burner a little bit in terms
of what it actually
represents.
Oh, my wife is here.
She's looking for our
filing cabinet.
But anyway, back to
what I was doing.
So let's put on the back
burner what a matrix is
actually representing and let's
learn the convention.
Because I think, at least
initially, that tends to be
the hardest part.
How do you add matrices?
How do you multiply matrices?
How do you invert matrices?
How do you find the determinant
of matrices?
All of those words might sound
unfamiliar unless you've
already been confused by them
in your algebra class.
I'm going to teach you all of
those things first, which are
all just really human-defined
conventions, and then later
on, I'll make a whole bunch of
videos on the intuition behind
them and what they actually
represent.
So let's get started.
So let's say I wanted to
add these two matrices.
Let's say the first one-- and
let me switch colors.
I'll do relatively small ones,
just so as not to waste space.
Say I have the matrix
3, negative 1, 2 0.
Let's call that A, capital A.
Let's say matrix B, and I'm
just making up numbers.
Matrix B is equal to
minus 7, 2, 3, 5.
So my question to you is what
is A-- so I'm doing it bold
like they do in the textbooks--
plus matrix B?
So I'm adding two matrices.
And once again, this is
just human convention.
Someone defined how
matrices add.
They could've defined it some
other way, but they said we're
going to make matrices add the
way I'm about to show you,
because it's useful for a
whole set of phenomena.
So when you add two matrices,
you essentially just add the
corresponding elements.
So how does that work?
Well, you add the element that
is in row 1, column 1 to the
elements in row 1,
column 1, right?
So it's 3 plus minus 7.
That'll be the 1, 1 element.
Then the row 1, column
2 element will be
minus 1 plus 2.
Let me put parentheses around
them so you know these are
separate elements.
And you can guess how
this keeps going.
This element will be 2 plus
3 and this last element
will be 0 plus 5.
So that equals 3 plus minus 7.
That is minus 4.
Minus 1 plus 2, that's 1.
2 plus 3 is 5, and
0 plus 5 is 5.
So there we have it.
That is how we humans
have defined the
addition of two matrices.
And by this definition, you
could imagine that this is
going to be the same thing
as B plus A, right?
And remember, this is something
we have to think
about because we're not adding
numbers anymore.
You know 1 plus 2 is the same
thing you is 2 plus 1, or you
know any two normal numbers, it
doesn't matter what order
you add them in.
But with matrices, it's not
completely obvious.
But when you define it in this
way, it doesn't matter if we
do A plus B or B
plus A, right?
If we did B plus A, this would
just say negative 7 plus 3.
This would say 2 plus
negative 1.
But it would come out
to the same values.
That is matrix addition.
And you could imagine, matrix
subtraction, it's essentially
the same thing.
Well, actually let
me show you.
What would be A minus B?
Well, this is capital B with the
matrix, so I'm making it
extra bold.
Well, that's the same thing
as A plus minus 1 times B.
And what's B?
Well, B is minus 7, 2, 3, 5.
When you multiply a scalar,
when you just multiply a
number times a matrix, you just
multiply the number times
every one of it's elements.
So that equals A, matrix
A, plus the matrix.
We just multiply this negative 1
times every element in here.
So 7, minus 2, minus 3, and 5.
And then we can do what
we did up there.
And we know what A is, so this
would equal-- A is up here, so
3 plus 7 is 10.
Negative 1 plus negative 2 is
minus 3, 2 plus minus 3 is
minus 1, and 0 plus 5 is 5.
Now, you didn't even have
to go through this
exercise right here.
You could have literally just
subtracted these elements from
these elements, and you would
have gotten the same value.
I did this because I wanted to
show you also that multiplying
a scalar or just a value or a
number times a matrix is just
multiplying that number
times all of the
elements of the matrix.
And so by this definition
of matrix
addition, what do we know?
Well, we know that both matrices
have to be the same
size by this definition,
the way we're adding.
So, for example, you could
add these two matrices.
You could add 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9 to this matrix, to
minus 10, minus 100, minus
1000-- I'm making up numbers--
1, 0, 0, 1, 0, 1.
You can add these two
matrices, right?
Because they have the same
number of rows and same number
of columns.
So for example, if you were to
add them, the first term up
here would be 1 plus minus 10,
so it would be minus 9.
2 plus minus 100 is minus 98.
I think you get the point.
You would have exactly nine
elements and you would have
three rows and three columns.
But you could not add
these two matrices.
You could not add-- Let me do
it in a different color just
so it's different.
You could not add this blue.
You could not add this matrix:
minus 3, 2 to the matrix 9, 7.
And why can you not add them?
Well, they don't have
corresponding
elements to add up.
This is a one row by two column,
this is 1 by 2, and
this is 2 by 1.
So they don't have the same
dimensions so we can't add or
subtract these matrices.
And this is a side note, when a
matrix has-- when one of its
dimensions is one-- so, for
example, here you have one row
and multiple columns, this is
actually called a row vector.
A vector is essentially a
one-dimensional matrix where
one of the dimensions is one.
So this is a row vector,
and similarly,
this is a column vector.
That's just a little extra
terminology you should know.
If you take linear algebra and
calculus, your professor might
use those terms and it's good
to be familiar with it.
But anyway, I'm pushing 11
minutes, so I will continue
this in the next video.
See